[Música]
como a
una historia
más pertinentes del emplazamiento
recuerda como un hobby además músico
bs
a un medio de altura
con una hoja y cinco pies
llegar al trabajo
sin aura su contrincante pero además por
la lanza y una espada
y eso lo dijo con la otan y la piedra
del río
ven se derrumba a su contricante la
historia por supuesto es la de david y
goliat
hoy les vengo a hablar de como un
pequeño negocio un davis después
competir ampliar a un gran negocio
dentro de su mercado
la estatua de vértice de la vida
muy famosa
pero primero luego apuntar un poquito
del pienso yo
y de la historia de mi familia mis
abuelos y abuelas y mi abuelo lo
que hago cada uno por su propio lado en
los años 30 a colombia muriendo
terribles
a mis heridas en el señor
llega a una
desconocieron
y allá el primero con ganas de sangre
ella hace nuestro presentó el examen
la gente que conoces
los cuales perdieron unas gotas yo
recuerdo no voy a recordar cuando bien
hubo esas ciudades poca gente años a
esta gracia al otro lado de los
almacenes veía
para todos los años creando comunidades
pero básicamente con la mamá sobre las
llamas y el vecino más pequeño
y el paro
pero eso
con la brega de euros
[Música]
la vivienda entonces
bella función los llevaron con el
acordeón
vamos a aprender apartamentos con una
edición anterior
d
y hay más
el lenguaje de la necesidad
o
el primer hotel de la cadena que llego a
hacer
la más grande cadena hotelera en el país
pero les cuento la historia por qué
en un momento de sinceridad domingo
solía ir a ese hotel con mi abuela a
comer el pan de yuca con mermelada de
guayaba me acuerdo y le pregunté abuela
que fue cuál fue como el mayor factor
para tu éxito con una tremenda cadena
hotelera
ella habla la polaca ni siquiera hablaba
polaco hablaba yiddish y aprendió
español con un acento vivís entonces con
el acento atropellado en español me dijo
pablo escobar
no porque la haya sido cliente o
inversionista de la empresa sino porque
era tanto el miedo que había a entrar a
colombia como mercado que no tenían
competencia lograron
crecer la empresa porque no había
básicamente nadie más haciéndolo no
había nadie más haciéndolo les digo yo
que mi familia emprendió hace diez años
con un hotel aquí en cali
que el panorama es radicalmente
diferente en el siglo 21 en colombia
por lo menos en la industria mía
seguramente en casi todas han
incursionado grandes multinacionales
en la hotelería hay marcas que tienen
miles de propiedades alrededor del mundo
cientos de miles de habitaciones que
alquilan cada noche y facturan miles de
millones de dólares al año y todas esas
empresas o casi todas tienen presencia
en cali nuestro hotel tiene las
estadísticas que se manejan dentro de la
industria uno contrata a ciertos
reportes
de mejor desempeño dentro de la ciudad
tenemos la tarifa promedio y la
ocupación y el respaldo bueno más altos
de la ciudad entonces hoy vengo a
hablarles en esos 10 años de experiencia
trabajando en familia como un david
emprendedor le puede competir a un
goliat competidor en un mercado
el primero
es tener un mejor producto suena
redundante pero la mejor forma de
competir es tener un mejor producto como
tener un mejor producto que sea más
fuerte o que rinda más o más eficiente o
de mejor calidad o con un mejor empaque
o que le llegue más rápido a tu
consumidor que el del competidor
en el caso nuestro
construimos habitaciones 50% más grandes
que el promedio en la industria con un
diseño abierto donde entra la luz
natural y las brisas que tanto nos
gustan cali a diferencia de la mayoría
de hoteles urbanos que son cerrados
oscuros
y encima de un centro comercial
no solamente no se le hubiera ocurrido a
una multinacional no lo hubieran podido
hacer por la segunda sugerencia y es que
uno debe tener uno tiene como pequeño
en negocios como emprendedor mejor
conocimiento de mercado
tiende ser que las grandes empresas
también tienen muchos empleados y esos
muchos empleados tienden
a rotar mandan un gerente de aquí y allá
y pierden ese feeling pierden ese tacto
pierden ese sentimiento de qué es lo que
está pasando en el día a día en un
mercado un pequeño negocio se puede dar
el lujo de ser más informal y de que
estén los directivos los gerentes los
administradores los dueños los
fundadores ahí escuchando viendo qué es
lo que pasa qué quiere el cliente
lo cual me lleva al tercer punto y es
que
una muy buena forma que puede competir
un pequeño negocio es siendo más ágil en
la toma de decisiones las grandes
empresas las multinacionales tienen
muchos empleados esos muchos empleados
tienden a generar una burocracia y esa
burocracia tiende a ser letárgica
tienen que reportar a la capital y la
capital
para volver ya
la capital tiene que reportar le a otro
país
y así sucesivamente en lo cual entorpece
sus procesos de toma de decisiones
nuevamente un pequeño negocio se puede
dar el lujo de conocer su mercado y
tomar decisiones rápidamente que van a
tener un efecto grande en el desempeño
de su día a día
pero todo eso no puede suceder sin tener
mejor y más personalizado servicio al
cliente a nadie le gusta hablar
con un centro de llamadas con un call
center o con un bot en un chat o con un
correo electrónico a nadie entonces un
pequeño negocio con su administrador o
su gerente o su dueño allí físicamente
puede decir buenas tardes cómo está cómo
me le ha ido
que le gustó que no le gustó cómo
podemos cambiar en el caso nuestro nos
sugieren algún ítem nuevo para el buffet
del desayuno o qué música les gustaría
escuchar en el restaurante
la quinta sugerencia es tener una
conciencia social
tener responsabilidad social corporativa
tener un impacto en la comunidad en la
cual funciona ese negocio ese pequeño
negocio en el caso nuestro
ejecutamos la feria del libro de cali a
través de nuestra fundación
casi cualquier proyecto que propone un
ente público hospedamos al speaker o el
músico o el conferencista que viene a
hablar
por darle un espaldarazo la ciudad por
mejorar nuestro entorno a mí me
enseñaron que
teniendo todo lo otro igual
un producto igual de bueno
un conocimiento de mercado tomando
buenas decisiones y con un excelente
servicio al cliente
un cliente va a decidir trabajar con uno
en últimas porque es amigo y no hay
mejor forma de ser amigo que extender la
mano y ayudar
y la última sugerencia
para poder competir como un pequeño
negocio es utilizar el internet como una
herramienta democratizadora solía ser
que las grandes empresas tenían marcas
piensen antes del internet antes incluso
de la televisión para poder
tener un sello de calidad un estándar
para que un cliente en otra parte del
mundo pudiera reconocer la calidad de
ese producto el internet no solamente
cambió eso lo demolió
lo destruyó porque hoy en día cualquier
persona se puede meter en google se
puede meter en twitter by share se puede
meter en la página de un bloguero y
saber exactamente qué experiencia tuvo
en tal negocio como le fue con tal
producto como usuario y deja una foto y
deja un comentario y eso juega a ventaja
de un emprendedor porque no es necesario
gastar millones de dólares en publicidad
o en mercadeo para poder dar a conocer
el mensaje y dar a conocer el producto
los emprendedores hoy en día
correctamente
son considerados los motores de
crecimiento
de una sociedad equivale mos a nuevas
empresas con más trabajos más impuestos
pagos
y mejores y más innovadoras ideas en
nuestro ecosistema y en nuestra sociedad
sin embargo le pesa al emprendedor la
incertidumbre y las barreras de acceso
al mercado que imponen los grandes
competidores en un mercado teniendo un
mejor producto conociendo mejor al
mercado tomando decisiones más ágiles
teniendo mejor y más personalizado
servicio al cliente
siendo socialmente responsable y
utilizando el internet como una
herramienta democratizador a los
pequeños negocios tienen con que espero
haberlos hecho pensar cuál va a ser su
onda y cuál van a ser sus cinco piedras
de río muchas gracias
[Música]
[Aplausos]